foreign
foreign
good evening Alderman councilors ladies
and gentlemen and welcome to this
extraordinary meeting of the council
before we formally start the meeting I
would like to wish everyone present a
happy
healthy prosperous and above all
hopefully a peaceful New Year thank you
yes you know
I have received apologies for absence
from counselors dagner Freeman Harding
and Bennett can I ask if anyone is aware
of any other apologies
councilor Dr Carter Dr Carl councilor
councilor Wright
councilor Mirza
Alderman Rigby are there any further
apologies
councilor holding a mentioned thank you
yep
final answers right no more apologies
thank you councilor Jarman
Council German yeah
okay
you'll be aware from the summons that
this extraordinary meeting has been
specially convened at the request of the
monitoring officer so that Council may
consider the election of a leader of the
council
the business this evening will be dealt
with like it would at any ordinary
meeting and as such we shall now proceed
with the main item
item one election of leader and a
membership of the executive
may I take this opportunity to
congratulate councilor Andrew Weston on
his successful election as a member of
parliament for the Stratford and urmston
constituency
a report is now
thank you
a report is now before Council regarding
the implications to the Council of his
election and I now invite councilor
Western to introduce the item councilor
Western
thank you chair and colleagues will be
aware that it falls upon me to
move the recommendation that councilor
Tom Ross becomes the leader of the
council moving forward I beg colleagues
Indulgence if I just take a few minutes
to speak more broadly about
my tenure as leader
the role that I think Tom will play for
the council moving forward before
returning to formally move the item it
has been the privilege of my life to
lead this local Authority since 2018 and
much has happened in that time
colleagues will need no reminder of some
of what this local Authority and indeed
the country has been through in terms of
the extraordinary economic circumstances
that we find ourselves in now the covert
pandemic which of course did so much
damage to us in health terms in economic
terms and in terms of the damage that it
did to the social fabric of our country
but it has been a privilege throughout
to serve you as leader of the council
and more importantly to serve each and
every one
of the residents of this phenomenal
Borough as the leader of the council it
um it's certainly odd to look back on
what is almost five years or as we now
seem to measure things for prime
ministers
to
um to consider what has happened in that
time but it's important not just to
think about the challenges that we have
faced and covid indeed was a challenge
like no other whatever your views on
covid or on lockdown it's certainly
stretched the local Authority in ways
that we had not seen before and
hopefully we will not see a game but
before that perhaps even more
challenging element of my political
career having to work in partnership
with the liberal Democrats but I have to
say that we have managed together as a
local Authority and on a cross-party
basis when necessary to do tremendous
work for our residents I particularly
want to draw out the building of the
first social homes in the local
Authority in decades not just for the
considerable policy achievement that
that was but also because of the name
that those homes carry about Court
somebody without whom I would not be the
leader of this Council or certainly
would not have been in 2018 19 and in
mentioning councilor Belk I want to
mention all of the group leaders who
I've worked with not just in my almost
five years as Council leader but
actually the eight years in which I have
been the leader of the labor group all
good people all wanting to do the best
for the borough as they saw it so
councilor new grosh counselor Jerome
councilor Blackburn my thanks for the
way in which you've worked with me in
your time as group leaders but also I
mentioned councilor belka councilor
Evans who for all our differences and
they normally play out on Twitter even
now
was so constructive and supportive for
the most part particularly during the
pandemic and councilor ansty who went
through an awful lot in his time as
leader of the council but was always
constructive and forever whatever rather
our differences always did what he
thought was best for the borough and
finally because she's here councilor
Coggins who
I have to say taking on the leadership
of a new group on the first day of her
election you would have expected
um needed some time to work things out
but was very quickly holding me and
anybody else who came within her orbit
to account and continues to do that now
but more than that proved herself and
this is rare
for opponents in politics to be somebody
who I could trust absolutely as indeed
was councilor balker because colleagues
who were here then know that I had to
take some very difficult decisions early
on in my tenure of a highly confidential
nature and it is always a risk to share
that information with people but
particularly Geraldine I want to thank
you for always being somebody who I was
able to trust in that period the Council
of course is nothing without its
officers and in particular whilst I pay
tribute to all of the officers that I've
worked with and that we've worked with
over the past nearly five years I want
to thank a few people in particular so
our current members of the corporate
leadership team who work every day
whether you agree or disagree with the
direction of the council that is not
their remit but to execute the wishes of
this chamber and in particular to serve
the people of Trafford to the best of
their ability in mentioning them I want
also to mention members of CLT who are
no longer part of the team Jane LeFevre
and Nikki Bishop in particular who did
such great work for the people of
Trafford and also Jill Colbert and Jim
Taylor who served on an interim basis as
Chief exec through what were disruptive
times through a change of administration
and a range of other issues here in the
local Authority
but there are two people who I want to
thank in particular and they are sat
either side of me
tonight so firstly Sarah who came to us
four years ago
um next month I think it was and had
something of an interesting start when
offstad came
um in on day one but throughout has led
this Authority with dedication passion
and enormous skill and on a personal
note has given me tremendous support
friendship and also shown what it is to
be a public servant Sarah thank you very
much for that and then Kath because Kath
and I have always worked as a team we
were elected as leader and Deputy leader
on the same day and I think that towers
of strength come in all shapes and sizes
and kath is often somebody who could be
underestimated
but is somebody who is absolutely
steadfast in her service of the people
of Trafford somebody who can always be
trusted and somebody who always places
people at the core of everything she
does she's somebody I've always been
able to trust and somebody who I have
always and will always absolutely
respect so Kath thank you very much for
your support these past not almost five
years but actually eight years
um as labor group leader I want to thank
all of my colleagues on a cross-party
basis I know that whatever difference is
we have we all care passionately about
this place and the people that live here
and I have always done my best to listen
to people whatever our political
differences if the point that they were
making was about how we get the best
possible outcomes for our residents but
I particularly want to thank my
colleagues in the late the group we have
come a long way in the past eight years
and indeed in the past five years to be
a group now of some 40 councilors and I
would not have believed that that was
possible
and so to lead you has been an enormous
honor you have been phenomenal to work
with as indeed have the colleagues
across all parties who are no longer in
this chamber
but I want to turn to the Future now and
of course I will still be here as the
Member of Parliament and I will still be
fighting for local government because it
is apparent to anybody regardless of
political colors that there is work to
do to make National parties all parties
recognize the work that we do and fund
us properly there are still incredible
challenges in the sector not just
Financial but in terms of needing needed
reforms to services like adult social
care
in particular
but I know that I could not be leaving
this Borough in better hands in Tom
councilor Tom Ross who I am delighted to
move as leader of the council he is
uniquely
experienced and ready for this task not
just having been a counselor for nearly
15 years now in Stratford but in
particular having had the I will use the
word pleasure Loosely the pleasure of
being the executive member for finance
these past four years he knows better
than anybody
what a challenge it is
to be at a senior level in local
government at the moment either as
counselors or indeed as officers it is
challenging but I know that he cares
about this Borough like me he has lived
in this Borough all his life and like me
I know he will do anything he can for
the people who live and work here so it
is my absolute pleasure tonight to move
the motion that councilor Tom Ross
become leader of the council he was an
outstanding mayor he has been a
brilliant executive member for finance
and I know that he will be an incredible
leader of this local Authority and so
with that chair I so move the councilor
Tom Ross become leader of Trafford
Council thank you
foreign
is that seconded please
yes um it is seconded thank you
um
chair
um so as usual
um councilor Western has uh has has said
it all
um but I did just want to add my own
thanks to Andrew
um it has been an incredible honor and a
privilege to to serve as Deputy leader
of this Council and to work with Andrew
over the past almost five years
um that time as Andrew as said has been
hugely significant I think for this
local Authority
um I think there have been some massive
challenges
um as Andrew talked about and most
notably I think the pandemic
um was was huge actually for the
residents of this Borough and I think
Andrew has guided and supported and led
this Council together with all of you in
in this chamber all of us actually
through those difficult times and those
challenges and Andrew again has
supported
um the most vulnerable residents
um in in Trafford
um and is is still doing so through the
cost of living crisis where we've seen
this Authority step up and support the
most vulnerable residents through some
incredibly difficult and challenging
times and it has been a real honor and a
privilege to work alongside Andrew who I
think has served with
um commitment he's served with passion I
think that we've all witnessed in this
chamber and I think he's been dedicated
to the residents of Trafford and he will
continue to be dedicated to the
residents certainly of Stratford and
Thompson but I would imagine so that all
of the residents of of Trafford going
forward and so I would like to place on
record my own personal thanks to Andrew
for all that he has has done for the
borough and I'm also incredibly proud
and feel privileged really to Second the
nomination for counselor Tom Ross to be
leader of the council and I think as
Andrew has said Tom does has already
displayed such
fantastic leadership qualities
throughout his time as a counselor and
as Andrew said most notably during his
time as as mayor of this Borough when
this Council chamber when the whole of
the the town hall was was full of
children and young people and I know
that that supporting children and young
people is a real passion
um of of TOMS and again Tom has
supported vulnerable residents and
during his mayoral year and was was
really significant in supporting
refugees into into our Borough
and I think Tom will serve with
integrity and will serve with passion
and commitment and like Andrew has said
I think this Borah will be in safe hands
under counselor Tom Ross so it gives me
great pleasure to Second the nomination
thank you
are there any other nominations
do any members wish to speak on this
matter
councilor Blackburn
councilor Acton
councilor new grosh
councilor Jerome
right
I'm going to start with councilor
Blackburn please
thank you Mr Mayor firstly
councilor Weston Andrew and
congratulations on becoming MP for
Stratford and urmston and as residents
we will closely follow what you're doing
in Westminster it's a vibrant
constituency with diverse communities
and proud of its past and looks forward
to its future so congratulations
um you progressed from being elected in
Priory reward in 2011 to become Deputy
group leader in 2014 and subsequently
group leader later that year which
culminated in your role as leader of
Council in 2018. you have of course leg
Trafford through the pandemic with its
health and its financial implications
that affected our residents and
businesses and oversaw all the changes
to the ways our staff are working during
and after lockdowns the life of the
leader of the council is not an easy one
and as your official opposition we
recognize and understand your commitment
and sacrifices made for our borough of
Trafford
as you continue to be in the council
chamber until May there will be time to
speak further about your 12 years of
service thank you
and that secondly the conservative group
is very happy to support the nomination
of councilor Tom Ross as the new leader
of our wonderful Trafford Council
um leader as a young temporary resident
and pupil at both Hayes Lane infants and
Junior school and altering and boys
grammar school you started on a route
where you were to achieve many roles in
life elected in 2008 in Stratford Ward
you're in both spokesperson for
supporting children and families and for
financing governance prior to becoming
the executive member for the latter
as the youngest mayor of Trafford in
2019 you experienced a successful and
enjoyable year with your mayor s Anne
and reached out and interacted with many
organizations During the period you're
almost 15 years as a Trafford counselor
including having the benefits of
professional workplace posts will enable
you to deal with the variety and breadth
of challenges that your position covers
good luck thank you
thank you councilor Blackburn the order
in which I have as speakers are
councilor Jerome councilor new gosh
councilor Acton and councilor Taylor in
that order there might be others I guess
so councilor Jerome please
thanks Joe
um first of all we'd also like to extend
a hand to Andrew and congratulate him on
becoming a the MP for Stratford and
urmston
um you've shown brilliant service to
this Council over the last um four four
to five years
um and you you've had a really tricky uh
tough time you know dealing with covid
and the many things that have come
forward and it's
it's shown through just how much you
care about the borough and how much you
care about the people in this Borough
um and that's Shone through again and
again and it's been amazing as well you
know dealing with Geraldine you've
yeah
you've been some great combat in this
chamber between between you and the many
group leaders and accounts that's been
great to Great to watch so
congratulations on becoming NP and good
luck and I hope that that goes well we'd
also like to extend a welcome to Tom Tom
as well I think the first words that I
spoke in this Council were to
congratulate you on becoming mayor and
when you did become there you you did
that job with such a passion with such
industry
um and I think you made more visits as a
mayor than probably any of them before
you but um it was amazing to see the
work that you did in that year and I'm
sure as you approached as a new leader
you'll show this the same passion and
integrity
um and work workload
um but also you're somebody that seems
to be very humble and approachable as
well and you've you always seem to have
a smile on your face so it'd be
interesting to work with you in the
future but we also kind of recognize the
challenge that you you face too I mean
councils across the country are facing
cuts that we've we've never seen the
like of before and and there are many
more places to be you know to cut within
councils and I'm sure your experience as
a executive member for finance will cut
come in full hand
um
but I also wanted to say that um there
has been some disappointments over the
last four to five years I mean the green
party
um
has been disappointed about the the
progress of the climate emergency which
has been cryogenic at times
um from the task and Finnish group that
moved very slowly
um having to push again to get the audit
that was promised within the motion
um but also we still don't have the data
to be able to track the progress on that
climate emergency so that's something we
continue to press you on
um clean air which has been a political
football between this Council Andy
Burnham and the government again our
residents being left with dirty air and
we're not doing enough there's so much
more that we could have been doing over
the last four to five years and we
haven't been so the green party will
continue to put pressure on it in there
and we want to see the changes in
infrastructure you know to help people
to walk and cycle
um and we still can't believe there's
only one School Street in this Borough
so far under this Administration if
that's not good enough and it's for
those reasons that we will be abstaining
from the vote tonight but of course
course you know we want we want to work
with all parties where we've got similar
aims and we're always extend a hand and
an open air to to work with you where we
we can
um but also
um
you know we've got a responsibility to
shout out for the residents of Trafford
too and you know we want to be able to
do that as a whole to account as much as
we possibly can but um it will hopefully
be great working with you Tom and uh
congratulations again and thank you
hello thank you councilor Jerome
councilman ugrash
thank you chair
I'd like to take this opportunity to add
my congratulations to council Andrew
Weston on his elevation to the commons
and to thank him for his service to the
council the borough and its residents
most notably his leadership and
Leadership is the word during the
Trafford council's response to the covid
pandemic
there was no perfect response to that
but I was impressed and and I hope that
our actions during that time made a
difference
however we're here to welcome councilor
Tom Ross as a new Council leader I'd
like to wish him all the best delivering
for the residents of Trafford in these
difficult times I hope that his
considerable experience especially
holding the finance portfolio has
prepared him for the considerable
challenges ahead
we wish you all the best for the future
for the years in the future ahead thank
you
thank you councilor new grosh uh
councilor Acton
thank thank you mayor
um
Andrew actually took over from me when I
stepped down
um there was I don't know how many years
ago it was eight yeah eight seven seven
years
um and I think he's been an absolute
outstanding leader leader of the labor
labor group and leader of this Council
and he's done it uh in style I believe
you know the way that he speaks in
Council has been brilliant and I think
the achievements that he's he he's had
um is second to none and you know I
think particularly around
um you know the support of adult care
and the Children's Services
has been amazing but I think also you
know building new houses
um the investment
in the Leisure centers uh our town
centers Stratford and
particularly Stratford Center that will
be transformed in the next few years and
I think that it is brilliant
and I think continuing
the work in in alteringham as well and I
think he cares about all the communities
and he supports all the all the
communities
throughout the borough and I think he
will also be an outstanding MP I'm sure
of that
and you know it's not an easy job to be
a leader of the council yeah every
difficulty you know passes your desk and
you know trying to plow through that can
be a lonely Place sometimes
um and I think you know but it but he's
kept at it and has been a brilliant
leader
and I think it's a shame that Dan said
what he did to say and he's going to
abstain because there are difficulties
that you you have when you're in
opposition it is a lot easier in terms
of say saying things when you're in
control it is so difficult to actually
deliver on every wish that people want
but I think he he's actually
you know spread his wings really to to
the leaders of the different groups that
we have in this Council now and I think
that's been a good thing because it is a
United thing and I think that you know
if the greens are going to abstain
that's their choice but I think it's the
wrong choice for tonight
and I think
um I think
now I'll just turn to Tom because I'm
absolutely certain that Tom will be a
brilliant leader I want to follow
Andrew and I think I know that Tom
listens to people and he
thinks about things quite deeply and
he's done a tremendous job Finance lead
in this Council in very very difficult
times and you know I I hope that all the
council Gets behind Tom and that we work
together in the future and I'm sure that
he will be that brilliant leader that
I've said before so thank you very much
Mr Mayor
thank thank you councilor Acton
councilor Taylor
on behalf of my colleagues in the labor
group I'm the chair of the labor group
and I certainly want to endorse uh Tom
as our leader it was an absolute
unanimous decision uh within the labor
group to support Tom's candidacy and we
have no doubt that he will continue to
safeguard the interests of this Borough
in the exceptional fashion in which
Andrew has done so
um I want to add my personal
congratulations to you Andrew as the
newly elected Member of Parliament for
Stratford and Amsterdam you have been an
absolutely exceptional leader of this
Borough and you have steered the borough
through some of the most difficult
challenging times in living memory
through austerity through the pandemic
and now through a cost of living crisis
and you have worked tirelessly and put
the interests of this Borough and its
residence first and I think often it's
great personal cost to yourself in a
most selfless way and we in this chamber
and the residents within Trafford owe
you a great debt of gratitude and I have
absolutely no doubt that Stratford and
ernstein constituency is in very safe
hands you will continue with that
um ethos of public service that you've
demonstrated so ably here um as the
leader of this Borough and
um
we will watch your career with interest
I have no doubts you will make your mark
empowerment very rapidly and will have a
meteoric career progression but not in a
selfish way because it is driven through
um through a desire to serve the public
and always work in their interests it's
been a great honor to work with you
you've been you've demonstrated such
exceptional leadership skills you've
been a great role model and I'm proud to
call your friend as well Andrew so thank
you for that and I'm sure my colleagues
in the labor group would absolutely Echo
that
um Tom I would like to say you have been
an exceptionally we came into this
chamber at the same time you have been a
valued colleague and remain a very good
friend Tom's track record speaks for
itself others have spoken about his time
when he was the mayor he did that with
great passion and dynamism and a sense
of fun as well and as I said the labor
group unanimously supported him in his
uh Candice candidacy Tom is uniquely
prepared for this role he has the
knowledge the skills the experience and
also the personal attributes and
qualities that are required to undertake
this role he's a deeply caring
individual and I know that he will
execute his duties uh with great uh
great skill and he will be a unifying
leader I think not only for us within
the group as Andrew was before but
within this chamber and I wouldn't know
what council acting has said I do think
it's a terrible shame that not all
parties can support his uh his
leadership without uh
unquestioningly but all I can say is Tom
that you certainly have our unfailing
support in the labor group and we wish
you well and we are right behind you so
many congratulations on the very best of
luck thank you
thank you councilor Taylor now I think
I've got two more wishing to speak which
is councilor Coggins and councilor
Brotherton I would remind everybody that
the motion actually is to endorse the
appointment of Tom Ross as leader of the
council that is the motion that is
before us and that is where we should
contain our remarks thank you
thank you mayor I'll I'll be very brief
I felt I needed a right of reply after
uh some of what I've heard I wanted to
congratulate both um Andrew and um and
preemptively Tom
um on their their new roles and um and
thank Andrew for his leadership over all
these years as as uh I'm perhaps
deviating mayor from what you've just
said but uh as you've heard on in 2018
it was a baptism of fire for us to
arrive into no overall control and
um and working together has has been a
um interesting and and actually
something I've learned from as well
um uh some of the big changes that
happened in that first year or two
especially including the appointment of
Sarah who uh as sure we all agrees a
massive asset to to Trafford and and I
think that was something that Andrew and
I were both heavily involved in
um and of course
um the decision to work cross-party
during the pandemic I think was very
mature decision that Andrew and Sarah
took for the benefit of of all the
people of Trafford and we working with
counselor Brophy and new Goshen and
Evans during that time was um well
eye-opening um amongst other things but
it actually worked really very well and
um in fact my comments on it I think
ended up in an LGA workbook on him on
how councils were tackling the pandemic
in a constructive cross-party way
um anyway I won't give you
um
we're just on the abstaining we
obviously have massive respect for all
the individuals involved and we wish
them the best what we said when we
arrived here in 2018 was that as the
first greens here we are here to bring a
different point of view we're not here
for unquestioning support and we you
know will work with all parties on the
issues that they that we agree on and
but we don't endorse the labor program
and that's why we're not voting for or
against anyone tonight and so it's not a
personal matter it's it's it's about um
I suppose maintaining our our
distinctive sense and so um best wishes
to you both in your new roles and I hope
that Tom finds another excuse to drive a
JCB in this one okay thank you
foreign
thank you councilor Coggins maybe he'll
find a reason rather than an excuse
councilor Brotherton
thank you Mr Mayor uh congratulations to
Andrew he's my my ward colleague for I
think 10 years now it doesn't seem that
long but it's 10 years and
it might seem longer to you
but the first time Andrew spoke at the
at a council meeting which I think was
in cell Town Hall most of us I think
recognize he would go far and uh
obviously that that's what's happened
but Andrew I'm sure knows it's not the
end of the journey in a few years time I
expect to look at my television if I'm
still here and see him on the front
government from bench of course and uh
and I'll be able to see I knew him when
he had an out yeah
now turning turn to Tom I I I really
like to take the liberty of speaking on
behalf of my late colleague councilor
Jane ball because Jane was the one I
think who met Tom uh at Alton grammar
school when he was a pupil there and
Jaylen comes to speak and I know she was
always a great supporter of Tom and Tom
if she was here I know she'd be
delighted to support and see how far you
got so I've taken your lead Mr maldu
endorse the uh the motion before the
council thank you
[Applause]
sorry I've counselor Brophy
my microphone not working
so in case you didn't hear me before I
wasn't intending to speak but I can't
let the moment pass without just
congratulating Andrew Western on
becoming an MP I'm sure you will do a
marvelous job in representing the
residents of Stratford and Hermiston and
it has been a pleasure to work with you
and I also wanted just to
um Echo the comments you made about
working with councilor balker and myself
during the partnership years
and I do thank you for the kind remarks
you made about my the late councilor
balker and the liberal Democrats because
it was an interesting time for Brazil
when we when we worked together in those
partnership times and finally keeping it
brief I just want to congratulate
councilor Ross it's again it's been a
pleasure working with you all these
years and I'm sure you'll be fantastic
in the role as leader of council and I
wish you luck in the role I'm sure it
won't be easy but I think you do have
the right qualifications with your
Finance background and on a personal
level I really wish you well in the role
foreign
before council is the nomination of
councilor Tom Ross as leader of the
council
can I ask if the council is in agreement
thank you
the appointment of councilor Tom Ross as
leader is carried
thank you
Anna and I will now invite our new
leader councilor Tom Ross to say a few
words on the occasion of his election
thank you mayor if you can talk to me
one moment
thank you mayor thank you for your
understanding there
um let me Begin by echoing the comments
of my predecessor that it is a privilege
of a lifetime to be elected as leader of
this Council I'd also like to pay
tribute to my friend and colleague
Andrew who has led this Council of
Distinction these past four years I know
he will be a very hard act to follow
when he first got the um the the role
and it was quite unexpected I think we
were expecting it the following year not
2018. um I was having a lovely time
being mayor and you know had the most
glorious year Andrew on the other hand
was dealing with some incredibly tough
incredibly challenging decisions that
took a lot of goods and courage and he
saw them through for the benefit of us
all in this Council so thank you very
much for that Andrew it is appreciated
by us all in here
I know that he's given a clear sense of
purpose to this Council based around our
current corporate priorities which are
supporting people through the cost of
living crisis reducing Health
inequalities and addressing climate
change and I know he will continue to be
a key Ally for us in Parliament and I
look forward to working with him as the
Member of Parliament for Stratford and
ermston
and whilst I'm here I'd just like to
also thank Kath for remaining as Deputy
leader of the council Cafe is one of the
most lovely people that I know not just
within politics but outside politics
she's someone that you can trust she
brings a very calm head situations and I
am incredibly grateful that she is
remaining as deputy and I look forward
to both was working as a very close team
in the months and hopefully years ahead
and I'd also like to thank my colleagues
in the group
um I have to say from from this
perspective it's coming up to my 25th
year campaigning in local politics and
there are a few faces in the room that
were there 25 years ago and that's very
good in terms of knowledge and
experience and and passing that through
the um Through the Ages so it's it's um
particular particular pride as I hit
that milestone in my local activity that
I've taken on this role not just as
Council leader but as leader of the
labor group it really is a privilege to
lead such a talented and committed and
diverse group of people
I think I'd also like to say thank you
as well to our officers for everything
that they do day in day out on the front
line behind the scenes to keep this
Council going people have alluded to my
role in in finance already quite a few
times and and there are challenges there
and there have been challenges now for
coming up to 13 years where many
services have been stripped back
it's been more difficult for councils to
function but I have to say that this
council is continuing to prioritize and
deliver Frontline Services as best we
can with the few resources that we have
at our disposal and that in no large
part is down to the hard work of all our
officers and I'd like to pay tribute to
them and I look forward to spending the
next few weeks and months going around
meeting teams with people and just
thanking them personally for all the
work that they can continue to do for us
I'd just like to set out a few things
that are a passion of mine that I'd like
to see happening in Trafford going
forward the first one being as has been
mentioned previously children and young
people
in many respects
I think children and young people have
have had a terrible deal this past 12 or
13 years
I've been in this chamber for 15 years
and I have seen when austerity came in
that the first Cuts came to those things
that supported children and those things
that supported young people whether it
be our sure starts whether it be our
youth services whether it be any other
Outreach programs that we have
um it's it's incredibly unfair and that
group of people who have grown up in a
very different world to the one that I
it was privileged has has known and on
top of that we had the pandemic where
for two years children were lacking in
terms of their access to full schooling
they couldn't socialize with their
friends on a on a normal basis if you
think back to when say you were 14 two
years out of a 14 year old life is huge
and we need to do everything we can and
it's my personal mission to make sure
that children and young people are a key
Focus for this Administration this
Council it's the least we can do after
the sacrifices that they have made to
keep us all safe in the last few years
so that is one thing that I'd like to to
drive forward
another thing echoing the um probably
the spirits of of councilor Jane bore
and I'm sure and I hope she will be
approving of of this is the the very
rich cultural and sports Heritage we
have in this Borough we have a very rich
and vibrant hintle and of um of Arts
culture Leisure Sport and Heritage in
Trafford and I know there is a lot more
that we can do to drive that forward and
really put Trafford on the map where it
deserves to be we've got a culture
strategy coming up imminently and we'll
be using that to underpin everything
that we do as a council and get arts and
culture and sports and access to those
um key things
to the people of of Trafford
in previous labor councils under Dave
Acton we managed to get the Imperial War
Museum and we managed to get the
Waterside Arts Center so where we have
ambition we know that we can achieve and
we will achieve and I look forward to
working with many of you around the uh
around the chamber to do that
another key thing for me which again I
can reference two of my predecessors
Andrew Weston and Barry Brotherton is
the creation of social housing I know
back in the the 80s when Barry was
leading this organization
um he um he was instrumental in driving
more social housing at that time we have
just got our first social housing in in
recent years under Andrew Weston we need
to do a lot more on that that is has
been a priority of us for a while and it
is something that I definitely want us
to focus on going forward I also want us
to look at The Chronic housing shortage
that we have in general and the waiting
lists we have of people families
individuals looking for adequate housing
in this Borough it's not going to change
overnight and I do know the scale of the
problems that we face in terms of the
housing crisis but we need to have a
renewed focus on that area to make sure
that everyone in Trafford manages to
access a decent home
moving on to the pressing Global issues
of our time and I just want to reflect
on the um the carbon neutral action plan
which I hope colleagues in the green
party understand it is a priority of
ours it remains a priority of ours we
know that it needs to underpin
everything that we do as a council we
will be going to be called we are going
to be Governor neutral by 2038 it is
going to be a key focus of this
Administration and we obviously look
forward to working with you in terms of
in terms of achieving that but what I
also want to focus on as well is the
sheer diversity of businesses and
industries that we have in Trafford
which means that we have the potential
to lead the national debate on the green
agenda Carrington for instance is will
soon be home of Trafford green energy
which the Pioneer in production of green
of green hydrogen fuel and we're already
working with Partners in Trafford Park
to make it into a Greener more
sustainable low carbon hood for industry
again we have the opportunity to be a
flagship for driving the green agenda
and that is something that I want us to
do
one of the other things I want to to
focus on is something that I'm simply
calling getting the basics right
everything we do as a council matters
including things like gritting roads
fixing road signs maintaining grass
verges
they matter and they must be done well
and to that end our contractors need to
recognize the importance that we place
as counselors and our residence place as
local residents on getting things right
first time and we will continue to hold
our contractors to account to make sure
that residents get the best possible
service from from from that organization
other challenges that we have are
integrating our Health and Social care
to improve our outcomes and reduce
Health inequalities that is something
that we've long Believe in and it's
something that we will Long Carry On um
working on
I look forward to Leading this Council
and making it to Trafford a best a good
place for everyone to live
I really want us to continue to drive
drive the down the Gap in inequalities I
want us to recognize what a diverse and
changing Borough we have how fortunate
we all are to live in such a Borough and
celebrate it more and I'd just like to
thank each and every one of you this
evening for the very kind comments that
have come my way across each party I
know that as I have said this before and
other people have said this as well
there is more that unites us than
divides us and that has always been
something that I've held close to my
heart and that is the way that I will
approach running this Council so thank
you so much everyone
it's the real privilege and a huge honor
to take on this role it has been very
humbling listening to all the lovely
comments this evening
I never thought I'd be in this position
certainly looking back to 25 years ago I
certainly didn't think I'd be in this
position let alone being uh being the
mayor of Trafford as well but I have to
say it just brings me joy each and every
day and I will work incredibly hard for
everyone in this Borough as we look
forward to the future so thank you
thank you leader councilor Ross and as
the neutral in the chamber may I offer
my personal congratulations to you that
then is the end of the meeting I thank
everyone for your attendance hope you
enjoy the rest of your evening if anyone
wishes to join me in the mayor's parlor
for refreshment you are very welcome
thank you once again please keep safe
good night